well we we we were lucky enough you know
to meet all the great masters of
architecture in design
you know from the conversation is when
the Royals from Alvar Aalto to Charles
Eames and it is nice to know them and if
you're not that stupid I like you too
so Arab parties is me you know any of
confusion was a well you know what it
was God at the time you know you can
imagine so I remember one time we were
traveling from Venice to from Milan to
vanish on training was going to give a
lecture in Venice or so and he was
traveling with a friend of mine an
architect very important actor Rogers at
the time and so of course I couldn't
resist and I went in the same
compartment where they were you know
start to talk and I was doing a mag like
the tension of magazine at the time so
you know just just like you know it was
very interesting interviewing you know
the great master you know and I remember
one point is said of all our sitting
next to the convention he said wow this
this young man is a lot of heat it was
summer tied together but it meant really
the kind of them well it was fun and
other stories about every every every
one of those big masters one night we
had dinner where several dinners in
Chicago witness but the Royal because I
was teaching at the Institute of desire
in Chicago and then and again very
exciting stories you will be tell I mean
he was a great storyteller so we will
tell stories of the Barcelona median how
he came about and all the thing that
happened during the construction and all
by me
thousand
an adult you know from every one of them
and I was fine it was fun
isn't so they you know I'm as I said was
a groupie so really this is why I'm
never annoyed when I whatever I go to
give lectures and I see young student
coming around you know love on the
signature and I understand that I was
doing the same thing you saw is fine I'm
not annoyed by that at all I mean and
and I'm glad actually I'm glad that in
they have some some examples somebody in
their mind that they you know is mental
and I mean at the end of the day that is
the most gratifying thing